this video is brought to you by nano
creators of virtual reality tools for
immersive molecular visualization and
interaction follow the link in the video
description to download nano man explore
molecules yourself
okay so quaternary structure refers to
the functional association or
interaction of or between two or more
polypeptide chains or subunits
okay now many proteins only have one
polypeptide chain okay and so they are
called monomeric proteins mono meaning
one and monomeric okay and so they have
no quaternary structure because
quaternary structure or for quantity
structure you have to have two or more
polypeptide chains okay now there are
many other proteins that have two or
more two plus polypeptide chains and
therefore they're called
multi marek proteins Multi marek
proteins and they do have quandary
structure okay
now depending on the how many ply
peptide chains make up a certain protein
there they'll have a need a more
specific name okay so like dimers tri
immers tetra Murs pentamers hexamers
four two three four five and six
polypeptide subunits respectively so
here I've got a little dimer right there
okay and then over here I've got a
little tetra mer right there four
subunits okay and dimers and tetra MERS
tend to actually be the most commonly
seen okay all right so now when it comes
to quaternary structure and you have
multiple peptides multiple polypeptides
that make up a protein those multiple
polypeptides or subunits are held
together by both non covalent
interactions and/or disulfide bonds okay
so so basically the same things that
hold together a tertiary structure can
also hold Kuantan Airy structure
together okay also the the multiple
peptides or subunits that are part of a
protein there sometimes I that identical
and then other times they're completely
different they're not related at all
they can also function independently of
each other but they can also work
together in fact there's there's this
concept called cooperativity
which just to give you this the skinny
on it it's the idea that the binding of
a ligand at one subunit increases the
affinity at the other subunits for that
ligand so they kind of all cooperate and
work together
hemoglobin exhibits that so that's kind
of the gist of of quandary structure a
lot of the times that it's not really
talked about that much but if you have a
protein that has multiple polypeptide
chains that make it up it's got
quaternary structure and it's worth
considering whether the different or
whether the the subunits are different
identical related all that sort of stuff
yeah I hope that video was helpful thank
you for watching